화면에 표시된 것처럼 다시 트레이스의 순환 성질을 이용해서요. 왜 이런 식으로 쓰고 싶은지 명확하지 않다면,
간단히 말하면 사영 측정이 밀도 행렬에 대해 어떻게 작동하는지 이해하고 싶기 때문이에요.
특히 선형성에 의해, X의 상태가 양자 상태 벡터 s가 아니라 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현된다면,
결과 a가 나타날 확률은 사영 Pi a와 밀도 행렬 ρ의 곱의 트레이스로 주어져요.
이렇게 되어야 하는 이유는, 앞서 살펴본 것처럼 밀도 행렬을 항상 순수 상태들의 가중 평균으로 생각할 수 있기 때문이에요.
그리고 해당 확률들을 평균하면 이 식을 얻게 되는데, 트레이스가 선형 함수이기 때문이에요. 바로 이게 우리가
얻으려는 식이에요. 밀도
행렬에 집중하도록 조금 정리할 수 있어요. 이렇게 하는 주된 목적은
이미 배운 내용과의 기준점을 세우기 위한 거예요.
그리고 사영 측정의 이 표현이 사실 곧 살펴볼 더 일반적인 측정 표현의 특수한 경우임을 확인하기 위해서이기도 하고요.
그래서 이제 밀도 행렬에 대한 사영 측정이 작동하는 방식의 표현을
일반적인 측정에 대한 표현으로 바꿔볼게요. 그러면 둘의 관계를 이해할 수 있어요. 여기 있어요.
반드시 사영 측정일 필요는 없는 일반적인 측정은, 합이 항등 행렬이 되는 양의 반정치
행렬들의 모음 p0부터 PM-1까지로 표현돼요. 그리고 이 측정이 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현된 상태의 X에 대해 수행되면,
각각의 결과 a는 PA × ρ의 트레이스와 같은 확률로 나타나요.
요약하면, 바뀐 것은 이 행렬들에 대한 조건을 완화했다는 것뿐이에요. 특히 이 행렬들은
사영 행렬일 필요가 없고, 그냥 양의 반정치이기만 하면 돼요. 그에 따라 Pi 대신 p라는 문자를 사용했는데,
Pi는 사영에 관용적으로 쓰이는 이름이지만, 저는 양의 반정치
행렬에 p를 쓰는 걸 더 좋아하거든요. 참고로 이건 사영 측정에 대한 표현의 일반화인데, 사영 행렬은 항상 양의
반정치이고, 실제로 고유값이
0과 1만 가능한 양의 반정치 행렬로 대안적으로 정의될 수도 있어요. 이 정의가
결과 확률에 대해 항상 확률 벡터를 얻는다는 점에서 의미가 있다는 걸 확인할 수 있어요.
첫째로, 결과 확률이라고 부르는 이 숫자들은 항상 음이 아닌 실수예요. 그건
PA와 ρ 모두 양의 반정치이고, 두 양의 반정치 행렬의 곱의 트레이스는
항상 음이 아닌 실수이기 때문이에요. 왜 그런지는 직접 생각해보세요.
둘째로, 이 숫자들의 합이 1이어야 해요. 트레이스가 선형이기 때문에,
p0부터 pN-1까지의 행렬들의 합이 항등 행렬이어야 하고, 밀도 행렬의 트레이스는 1이에요.
따라서 어떤 밀도 행렬 ρ에서 시작하더라도, 결과 확률들은 항상 확률 벡터를 이뤄요.
이제 몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 사영 측정이 일반적인 측정의 특수한 경우라는 건 이미 말했는데,
사영이 항상 양의 반정치이기 때문이에요. 하지만 간단한 것부터 시작하는 게 좋으니까, qubit의 표준 기저 측정부터 시작해볼게요.
qubit의 표준 기저 측정은 두 행렬 p0와 p1로 표현할 수 있는데,
화면에 표시된 것처럼 정의돼요. p0는 |0⟩⟨0|이고, p1은 |1⟩⟨1|이에요. 둘 다 양의 반정치 행렬이고 사실 사영이기도 해서 분명히 합이 항등 행렬이 돼요.
그래서 함께 측정을 표현해요. 이 측정을 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현된 상태의 qubit에 적용하면,
결과 0이 나타날 확률은 p0 × ρ의 트레이스예요.
그리고 결과 1이 나타날 확률은 p1 × ρ의 트레이스예요. 트레이스의 순환 성질에 의해
예상대로 ρ의 두 대각 원소를 얻게 돼요. 또 다른 예시인데,
이번엔 행렬들이 사영이 아니에요. 하지만 양의 반정치이고, 밀도
행렬이기도 해요. 하지만 그건 중요하지 않고, 중요한 건 합이 항등 행렬이 된다는 거예요. 그래서 함께
측정을 표현해요. 이 측정이 플러스 상태의 qubit에 수행될 때 어떻게 되는지 볼 수 있어요. 예를 들어
어떤 한 상태에 대해 어떻게 작동하는지 보기 위해서요. 확률의 계산은 화면에
표시돼 있어요. 특히, 플러스 상태가 순수 상태이고 양자 상태 벡터 |+⟩로 표현할 수 있지만,
확률을 얻으려면 그 상태의 밀도 행렬 표현인 |+⟩⟨+|를 공식에 대입해야 한다는 점을 주목해요.
그리고 파괴적 측정에 대해 이야기하고 있기 때문에, 이 qubit의 측정 후 양자 상태에 대한
명세가 없다는 점도 알아두세요. 그래서 결과
확률의 명세만 있어요. 지금으로선 마지막 예시인데, 꽤 흥미로운 거예요. 또 다시 단일
qubit의 측정이고, 이를 표현하기 위해 사면체
상태라고 알려진 네 가지 양자 상태 벡터를 정의하는 것부터 시작할게요.
이것들이 사면체 상태라고 불리는 이유는 블로흐 구에 내접하는
정사면체의 네 꼭짓점에 해당하기 때문이에요. 정사면체라고 할 때는
각 면이 정삼각형인 사면체를 의미해요. 완벽한 대칭이 있어서, 모든
변의 길이가 같고 어떤 두 인접한 변 사이에 형성되는 각도도 같아요.
이제 화면에 표시된 것처럼 네 가지 가능한 결과를 가진 흥미로운 측정을 정의할 수 있어요. 말로 하면,
이 상태들의 밀도 행렬 표현을 2로 나눈 것을 행렬로 사용할 수 있어요. 이건 분명히 양의
반정치 행렬이에요. 밀도 행렬을 2로 나눈 것이니까요. 합이 실제로 항등 행렬이 되는지 확인하는 계산을 직접 해볼 수도 있지만,
다른 방법으로는 대칭성을 생각해볼 수 있어요. 이 네 상태를 평균하면
블로흐 구의 중심에 있는 완전 혼합 상태를 얻게 돼요. 하지만 네 개가 아닌
두 개로 나누기 때문에 완전 혼합 상태의 두 배, 즉 항등 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 이 측정에 대해서는
지금은 더 말하지 않을게요. 사영 측정이 아니지만 좋은 예시라는 점만 관찰하고,
이 강의 후반부에서 다시 등장할 거예요. 일반적인 측정을 표현하는 또 다른 방법은 채널로서인데, 이제
살펴볼게요. 여기서 아이디어는 고전적인 확률 상태는 대각 밀도 행렬로 표현될 수 있다는 거예요.
측정 결과는 고전적이기 때문에, 측정을 출력이 항상 대각 밀도 행렬인 채널로 생각할 수 있어요.